here are my top 10 tips to get your  first Cloud job number one understand  cloud computing understand a high level  Market perspective in terms of jobs  Cloud specific roles kind of expertise  and experience needed to do those jobs  number two identify the opportunity  areas opportunities in cloud or across  Industries and various expertise areas  infrastructure networking security pick  your thing number three Community is  important join a local community where  peers discuss Topics in areas that  they're working on you are likely to  hear about job opportunities from here  number four communication skills and  technical skills is really a winning  combination so work on that number five  be authentic cloud is a vast area with  which is also very fast moving so  identify an area or two within cloud  provider that interests you